what's he into these days I'm trying to
marry myself 11 now's I don't remember
what happens at 7 I wasn't there at the
thought I lived on a Greek island for
much of his childhood what what's
happening now with the 7 year old oh you
know he's in a lot of things but he's
you know mostly right now he was into
geography and Islands and now he's
really into exotic fruits all kinds of
exotic fruits we have to like troll the
internet to find which exotic suits will
come and you wants to think about mom
can we travel here to get that and now
he's into exotic fruits that's I mean I
what you're gonna say like oh he's
playing video games all day long we
can't stop him trolling the internet but
looking for exotic fruit that's quite
unusual does he like to taste them too
or does he just want to taste them okay
yeah he has an amazing palate we go to
this place in Van Nuys and like it's
very you know it's a market where you
know you don't usually see a kid that
knows about all the fruits and he's just
like well what about this and how does
that smell and I want to eat this and
that and me what about you that's a it
is a massive priority could you ever do
you have any fruit trees in your
neighborhood you have yes no I'm so we
have my mom I don't know if there's
actually a true legal thing but if the
fruit is hanging over the fence or on
the sidewalk you could take it I heard a
car was parked near your house you
should take it
wait so are you are you it so you're
taking fruits do you ever jump someone's
fence and take if they have an exotic
fruit our son wants it oh that's a you
know it's right there but it's right
there get it I'm like oh but if it's if
it's on the other side oh you'll find me
upside the road right picking
pomegranates or prickly pears with
cactuses right right so you're just if I
it wouldn't be so if I was driving down
the street it wouldn't be unusual for me
to see you like in a thorny bush trying
to forage some fruits for your son sadly
not and you but you still feel like
you're stealing right that's the funny
bit like you're like though it's okay to
do this but they like vasco rat run
you're not stealing it's from God
that's the way to look at it you're
stealing but from God
you